this is the first video in a new series
directed at people who would like to
engage in self-directed study of great
thinkers texts and topics in the field
of philosophy which is my area of
specialization i get asked quite
frequently by viewers subscribers fans
people who come to my talks
how can i study philosophy on my own is
that possible for me is it feasible or
do i need to go to a college in a
university or sign up for some mooc or
something along those lines is it really
possible for me and the answer is yes
anybody can study philosophy
but there are a lot of things to keep in
mind and people then immediately ask
where should i start and my answer is
almost always let's start with
plato plato there's a lot of reasons why
we should begin with him and i'm going
to talk about that in a bit so this
video is just about plato
and
what you might think about or take into
consideration as you're beginning your
studies or continuing your studies as
you're approaching his texts as you're
digging into the dialogues i'm going to
give you some useful at least i hope
it's useful for you advice and pointers
and bring up some things that you might
otherwise
miss and i'm drawing upon
about you know 20 years of teaching
plato i guess you could say that i have
about 30 years experience of reading
plato or maybe even longer i'd have to
think about exactly when it started
because i know i got introduced to plato
in high school
and i've been helping people
outside of the field of academic
philosophy
engage with with philosophical thinkers
and texts i'd say about the last 10
years so i've got some ideas in mind
that might be helpful for you i'm going
to be bringing up a lot of different
points in no particular order
if you
find something in here that's not
particularly interesting just skip ahead
but hopefully all of it should be useful
for at least somebody
the first topic that we should think
about is well why should we study plato
in the first place meaning not just why
should we study plato at all but why
should plato be one of the first
philosophers who we examine why not
start with some 20th or 21st century
thinkers somebody who's really
contemporary or why not
branch out into the the wider world of
non-western philosophy and maybe look at
you know confucius or laozi or some some
other writings or
why not start if we're going to begin
with western philosophy plato's not the
first philosopher why not begin with the
people that we call the pre-socratics
and there are some good reasons for this
um when it comes to the contemporary
stuff you know philosophy is a
conversation that's been going on here
in the west for over 2 000 years and you
you can find some stuff in the in the
present that doesn't really connect up
much with with philosophy's history
but um much of what you would encounter
will have some reference to the past so
it's it's not always helpful to jump
right into the the newest stuff the
newest is not always the best when it
comes to philosophy when it comes to
what we might call world philosophy or
comparative philosophy or non-western
philosophy there's nothing preventing
you from doing that
but if you want to study western
philosophy which is what i can help you
with because i'm not an expert in
comparative or non-western philosophy i
think plato is a really good place to
begin
and you might say well that's all fine
but i know that there were some other
thinkers before plato these
pre-socratics like heraclitus whom i
might have heard of or parmenides or
pythagoras
and yes that's quite true but
when it comes to possessing full texts
plato's really the beginning
we don't have more than fragments or
very short selections from most of these
pre-socratic thinkers and as a matter of
fact a lot of what we know about them
comes to us through plato
perhaps mediated through socrates
plato's great teacher uh and his
reflections on it or perhaps plato's own
study of these thinkers and so if we
want to begin from a
fairly systematic beginning point
plato's more the place to start
you're going to get plenty of the
pre-socratics
in in studying plato and there's nothing
to prevent you from going back and
reading them anyway but i think that
plato is really a good starting point so
he's really the first
developed
philosophical thought that we have
access to now you know we could have
some great discovery and find
heraclitus's
treaties on nature or democritus or or
you know pythagorean writings or
something like that that could happen
but until it does
plato is really the place for us to
begin with
another key thing that i think
recommends plato is you're really
getting a double whammy you're getting a
lot of plato's views
but you're also getting
some representative discussion
of his teacher socrates who is a major
thinker of the early western world and
not just in terms of platonism socrates
had a number of different followers who
each you know established their own
school
we don't have a lot unfortunately of
some of the what we call minor socratic
schools like the cynics and the cyrenaic
hedonist school or the magarian
dialectical school
but we do have you know xenophon
who is another
student of socrates and we can kind of
take plato and xenophon and compare them
and contrast them and get a composite
picture of this guy socrates but our
most developed picture of socrates is
really coming through plato
and so
when you read about
uh socrates and the platonic dialogues
you can get a good sense of who this
person was and why he mattered so much
plato is also going to be
referenced by many other philosophers
love them or hate them
they're talking about plato it's not
quite true to say as alfred north white
had apparently did that you know
philosophy is a set of footnotes to
plato that's going too far there's a lot
of originality and new ideas coming
about
through other thinkers including plato's
own student
aristotle who founds his own school but
plato is an absolutely central
partner in the conversation that is
philosophy and indeed culture in general
in the west
going up to the present like i said you
know whether you agree with plato or
whether you think that he's the the
origin of all sorts of problems and
misunderstandings the way you know some
philosophers do portray him like for
example friedrich nietzsche
um
he's somebody you need to know he's
somebody who is worth studying so that
you have a good sense of what's going on
in philosophy
so
those are some some good reasons to to
study plato i would say that there's a
few others that we might bring up
one is that we're going to talk about
this a little bit more when we go into
what a dialogue consists of
what's really cool about plato's
dialogues is that they're they're
genuine dialogues they're not just
you might say
pasteboard characters who don't really
disagree with each other embody some
sort of point of view you'll get to
learn a lot about
you might say ancient athens and greece
in general and different ways of
approaching
issues and problems not just in
philosophy i mean you're getting a lot
of as i said pre-socratic philosophers
and the people that we call the sophists
and rhetoricians
you're also getting military leaders
you're also getting people who are
cultural producers who are trying to
explain or produce poetry you're getting
crafts people you're getting all sorts
of people represented in these socratic
dialogues
and so
you know we
get to to try out a number of different
ways of looking at the world and they
they come into conflict and conversation
with each other
in plato you will find some very central
problems and questions and topics of
philosophy being raised for example what
is knowledge plato sets the bar rather
high
but he is at least approaching the
problem in a constructive way
or who should run the
political system or
what are the virtues and what are the
vices or how do we become good people
these are all just a few of the many
different philosophical topics that
plato is addressing i'll just throw one
more in there that i think is
particularly important
what are universals
when we say that you know i'm a human
being and you're a human being
what's the human beingness that we have
in common
that's a really central problem that
that plato addresses in terms of what he
calls the forms or ideas
so there are central problems or issues
or topics that you'll get introduced to
in studying plato
his works are very challenging but
they're also incredibly rich
and rewarding and you can study them
really the rest of your life if you
wanted to so there's no sense in
delaying why not just jump right in
the other thing that i think is really
great about plato is if you're studying
the platonic dialogues you're going to
be attending to
assumptions that people are making
and arguments
and distinctions
and getting introduced to concepts
you're acquiring the tool kit that
you'll need in order to do
philosophy in relation to other people
so these are all some great reasons for
beginning with plato
as you're beginning there are some very
practical questions about text that we
should get out of the way
the first thing that people want to know
is which dialogues which works by plato
should i be reading first
and you know the answer to that is you
can really start anywhere you like
you're not going to hurt yourself by
beginning with the republic or the
symposium or even with the you know
late work like the laws
that said i think that there
there are some dialogues that are easier
for beginners to wrap their heads around
and see where plato's going and get some
sense of
you know what what the platonic project
as a whole is
other people may may recommend different
reading orders and that's perfectly fine
i'm just going to give you the one that
i particularly like and i will point out
that it's not exactly the same as what i
do in like my introduction to philosophy
classes or foundations in philosophy
when i'm teaching it in an academic
institution but for self-study here's
the order that i think is for many
people going to be the most productive
start with two dialogues one of them is
really really short and a bit confusing
but you can figure it out and it's
called the ion and the other one is a
bit longer there's a bit more going on
in there also probably going to be
confusing at first but you'll puzzle it
out and that is called the meno
why do i pick these two dialogues
well they're both
fairly
you know early and they they are part of
a chronology where you get to see things
happening with socrates uh the amino is
a later dialogue as far as its
composition but but it fits into this
nice narrative that we we see going on
and they both deal with a fundamental
set of questions
who actually knows what the hell they're
talking about who has
knowledge episteme in in greek
and
the answer isn't made completely clear
but at least we get to take some people
off the stage and say well these people
don't know what they're talking about in
the ion which is the shortest of the
dialogues socrates is talking with a guy
named ion which is why it's called the
ion and ion is a rhapsody he's
explaining uh what it is that he does
which is to go around and interpret
homer's poetry and socrates asks them
some pointed questions and it turns out
that what ion does
he's doing not by knowledge but by
something like divine enthusiasm or a
communication of emotion so there's some
really interesting stuff going on there
the meno which is a little bit longer
named after another guy mino a friend of
socrates involves a lot of discussion
about the nature of virtue and
whether virtue is something that can be
taught
can we define virtue
it turns out in that dialogue they're
not able to come to a definition but
eventually in other dialogues they do
and these are really great starting
points
in it you also see foreshadowing of
socrates trial and death because there's
a guy who shows up annitus and he and
socrates get into a little bit of a tiff
with each other
after you've read those dialogues and
not you know when i say read them i
don't mean reading them once i mean
reading them through a number of times
and studying them and mulling them over
then i would say you're ready to move on
to a new sequence of dialogues and and
there i would begin with a set that you
can often find uh in in the last days of
socrates those would be the euthyphro
the apology
the credo and the phaedo
why are all these associated with each
other because they have to do with
socrates trial
and his
condemnation
and his eventual execution
the euthyphro deals with the question of
what pie it is because socrates is being
accused of impiety and the apology is
his defense speech which doesn't defend
him all that well but lays out a lot of
the doctrines and again explores issues
of knowledge and who has it and who
doesn't why socrates is a wise person
even though he doesn't know very much
and some of socrates views on death and
then the credo
has to do with whether he should take
the opportunity to slip away from the
prison cell that that he's awaiting his
execution in because his friend credo
bribed the jailers or whether it be
wrong to do so
finally the phaedos a really long and
great dialogue introduces a lot of
platonic concepts and depicts the death
of socrates on the day that he died he
was having conversations with his
friends about the immortality of the
soul and arguments for it and against it
and the nature of philosophy and the
relation between the soul and the body
so those those are those six dialogues
great starting point now where do you go
after that well
you have a lot of different options if
you're particularly interested in the
question of language and rhetoric you
might read the gorgius
and the protagoras
and
other dialogues like the cradles if you
want to dive right into the republic
which is one of uh
the the longest and in some respects
best works of plato there's nothing to
prevent you from doing that you might
also go another route and look at the
dialogues on friendship and love which
would be the lysis the symposium which
is one of the finest works of western
literature and the phaedras
it doesn't really matter i think too
much which order you read them in people
get
very worked up about it's got to be in
the right order you're not going to hurt
yourself by reading books out of order
because you have to remember you're
going to go back and re-read these
over and over and over again so don't
get too preoccupied with that
um
there's you know it really depends on
what you're particularly interested in
then we can think about questions of
what book should i actually get you know
let's get down to the nitty-gritty
um
do i get this translation or this
translation or this translation and
again people get very
uh concerned about having the right
version there is no right version i'll
tell you as somebody who's engaged in a
lot of translation work
you're never truly happy as a translator
with the translation that you make of
things from one language to another
and um
you know
you can find translations that are good
in one respect but not good in another
you're almost better off actually
comparing them with each other if you if
you can't read it in the original greek
and plato's greek by the way is quite
hard um
it's demanding um
you don't have to be overly concerned
about it what you really want to do
is make sure that you have access to
multiple versions and that you can find
a translation that's readable for you
now one of the things that i i do
recommend
is getting an anthology and i have an
older anthology here
which is um edited by edith hamilton and
huntington cairns this was sort of the
standard
version back when i was in graduate
school it's got most of plato's
dialogues certainly all the ones that
are actually attributed to him and even
some dialogues that we think you know
might not actually be by plato
you know you can notice it's been quite
you know
footnoted for not footnoted but uh
post-it noted for for me because i i
use this quite a lot and um it gets a
you know this
sort of thin paper that you see in big
thick books this is not a bad version to
have
um there is a more recent
uh
set of translations that you can also
get an anthology form edited by
if i remember right cooper and annis and
i'll put links to both of those in the
video below again don't get too
preoccupied about having the right text
it's important just to get get your
hands on some plato
and you know you don't necessarily have
to buy it you can find plato at your
local library very very commonly right
you might even find an anthology like
this
you can also find plato online there are
a lot of platonic texts available in a
variety of different translations and
sources
there's even something that's called the
perseus project that will allow you to
you know if you want to look at the
greek you could you can do that in the
the perseus project website which is uh
hosted by tufts university so you don't
have to worry too much about which
translations or which editions the key
thing is to get yourself something that
works for you
um people are also quite concerned very
typically
with
secondary literature and and i think a
lot of this comes out of the feeling
that i don't know if i'm really up to
reading plato you know it's challenging
work he's got such a great reputation
who am i to approach plato and make make
sense of it i i don't know that i'll
actually get that much out of it maybe i
should read an intro to philosophy or a
history of philosophy or something like
that and if you want to do that there's
there's nothing wrong with that
i always tell people including my
face-to-face students and online
students that
with the right resources with the right
support
anybody can study philosophy but if you
want secondary literature there's
certainly plenty of it out there i
actually picked out a few things off of
my bookshelf
two very different uh
writers and approaches like here's
gregory vlastos socrates ironist and
moral philosopher vlastos is an is an
academic and he takes a very analytic
approach to
socrates and to plato and i don't agree
entirely with everything that he has to
say but i i do respect him as a an
author and i think he's worth reading
that said something like this is going
to be written in a rather
you know it's for an academic audience
it's written at a high level you'll find
things referenced here it may not
actually help you understand
what what plato and socrates are up to
stanley rosen kind of a similar thing
here's his excellent commentary on
plato's symposium way longer than
plato's book of course because he's
going into great detail about it rosen
is much more historically oriented so if
you read this you'll get a lot of
background on you know what the
references are and who he's talking
about rosen also likes to throw a lot of
his own spin in there too and that's one
of the things with secondary literature
you're not going to find histories of
philosophy that don't have a certain
bent or sometimes even bias
aiming at a certain way of understanding
the material emphasizing some things
de-emphasizing other things so you know
it's good to to read secondary
literature but you should realize that
you're relying on somebody else to tell
you
what to think and so you want to
approach it with that proverbial
grain of salt don't you
one of the people who i particularly
like i'm gesturing over that way because
he's on my bookshelf over there is
friedrich cobbleston i'll put a link to
his history of philosophy that was sort
of a standard reference guide for us
back in graduate school again written at
a fairly academic level
but
you know cobblestone at least won't
steer you wrong
sometimes he can be a little dry and
dull but
he's reliable as opposed to say you know
bertrand russell i wouldn't recommend
his history of philosophy for
understanding plato um or you know other
other people who reference him as well
you could go to popular literature like
you know plato at the googleplex or
things like that but that's dicey
you know you never know if you're
getting the straight stuff
the only way to tell if the person
really does understand plato is for you
to read plato so why not cut out the
middle person and go directly to the
text itself and then then go to the
secondary literature and see if that
helps you if you really really want
secondary literature
again i recommend going to your local
library
particularly if you are able to access a
university library and
um seeing what the secondary literature
is you'll find it in the same shelf area
as plato's own writings
or if you want to find texts online
one of the things that you can do
is go to google scholar you have to
actually type it in google scholar and
then you can find pdfs
of whatever is available academic
articles on on plato as well as all
sorts of other things another good
website for that is academia.edu
where academics tend to upload their
their
publications so you can find a lot of
stuff for free that way so you know
those are i think the the
things that people need to know the most
about the practical questions which
dialogue should i read first
what order you know
what editions what translations and what
about secondary literature
now we get to a part of this that i'm
actually much more interested in and
passionate about and that's advice about
how to start
you got yourself a platonic dialogue
you're going to read it you're going to
reread it because you're going to get
confused as hell the first time around
unless you're very unusual
what are some suggestions for how to
approach it how to get the most out of
it
so
right off the bat the first thing i have
to say is
when you're reading philosophy and this
doesn't just go for plato this goes for
any great philosopher do not expect that
you're going to read it the first time
and you're going to get everything out
of it it just does not work that way as
a matter of fact what makes these texts
classics is the fact that they are so
rich that you can go to them over and
over and over again
in the course of decades and still find
other stuff that you might have missed
or not paid attention to or downplayed
and you get a better and better picture
uh as you do it so the first reading you
might not even understand half of what
you're reading that's okay
don't don't put so much stress on
yourself that you have to grasp
everything when you're reading it you
know i would say give it a good you know
once over read it all the way through
don't worry about the stuff that you're
not understanding then go back and then
start you know maybe taking notes or
worrying about what's going on in this
passage
you should also try to suspend whatever
assumptions you have about what
philosophy is or anything you've already
learned about plato or socrates that
doesn't mean you have to throw it away
but just like you know
realize that you could have gotten
misinformation
or you could be off base about it or
perhaps you misheard or misread
something
it's also helpful not to come in with a
lot of assumptions about what philosophy
is or how it has to be done
plato is one of the people who's doing
philosophy long before any of us come on
the scene and before any of the other
people who decide how philosophy has to
be done are
arriving oftentimes you know
taking him into account
another thing is that
plato is writing dialogues and i'm going
to talk in a few minutes about what a
dialogue requires
of you as the reader so you want to
realize that there is something
systematic something valuable
something intellectual
something developmental going on in each
of the dialogues if you don't get it
right off the bat that's okay
it's there
and
the more that you work at it
the better you're going to understand
what's happening there
it's not going to be presented to you in
a systematic form the way it would be in
a textbook
these are not intro to philosophy
textbooks these dialogues they're not
philosophical treatises they are actual
dialogues between characters who discuss
ideas and sometimes get into actual
arguments with each other and go back
and forth and don't always finish all of
their thoughts
so
pay attention to what's going on realize
that you are gradually building a map
of what's happening in the dialogue and
it's a map of what's there
but it's not going to be all there on
the surface and the organization is not
going to be totally apparent to you
the other thing i want to say is
have some faith
have some faith or hope or confidence
whatever it is that you want to call it
have some of that in two things
one is in the text
people wouldn't have been reading this
for years and years and years and you
know saving plato most of ancient
literature we've lost we have plato
and people wouldn't be going back to
this over and over and over again if
there wasn't something valuable there
maybe you don't get it the first time
maybe you don't get it the tenth time
but it's there so have some some
confidence that if you
put the work in you will get something
out of it
put some confidence in yourself
i think that
every person is capable of reading works
of philosophy
and getting something out of it not
everyone will get the same thing at
every every given time but everyone is
able to get something out of studying
philosophy and you're no exception
with the right support with the right
advice with the right application
you can make a lot of progress
even without an academic advisor or
classroom setting you can study plato on
your own and come to understand a lot of
it the last thing that i want to stress
is that what's really core at the
beginning
is not developing
a sense of whether you agree or disagree
with plato that happens later
what's more important is understanding
understanding is the ground you know or
foundation
after which that's been laid you can
decide whether you appreciate what's
going on or whether you agree with it
but if you don't understand it you have
no idea what you're disagreeing with if
you disagree with it if you don't
understand it and you say oh i love
plato he's so wonderful
you don't actually know what you're
you're appreciating
the key is to develop a solid
understanding of what it is that plato
is actually telling us so those are some
some tips that i think could be quite
helpful for you
i do also have a few things to say
specifically about the dialogue form
and what it offers to you and what it
requires of you as a reader and the
first thing is don't expect a dialogue
to be something different than a
dialogue i already talked about this a
bit these are not systematic treatises
even though they have a systematic
structure to them they are dialogues
they are conversations between people
they contain some parts that might be
very systematic for example in the
republic but a lot of the time the the
conversation is is going back and forth
and meandering from point to point
you have to be the one who does the work
to put these things together so you
actually have to follow the dialogue
that means that
one of the key things that you have to
be able to do
is figure out who is saying what at what
point depending on the translation that
you have
and which text we're talking about
you can sometimes lose the thread of
that you might want to do what they do
in plays right and put you know s for
socrates and g for gorgeous or m fermino
or whatever right next to those people
that's fine you can deface your books
however you like if it helps you out
the dialogue form requires you to
distinguish between the different
speakers
and the different speakers in a platonic
dialogue
are different precisely because they
represent different points of view
they're not just a bunch of people who
are all on the same page you know there
are some places where socrates is
talking with glaucon and glaucon is
socrates will say this and this and this
and then glaucon says oh yes socrates i
see that now and there's some of that
but there's a lot of well here's what i
think well here's what i see wrong with
what you think oh really but what about
this oh yeah i get that you have to be
able to distinguish these two speakers
or three speakers or five speakers apart
from each other so you're not confusing
them with each other
in many of the dialogues the person who
is representing plato's point of view is
socrates but there are even a few
dialogues where socrates is the one
who's listening to somebody else
explaining things so you want to be able
to differentiate
between the different points of view and
the different voices that are involved
just like you would with a shakespeare
play right
or a more modern play eugene o'neill or
pick whoever you like
the different voices are coming from
different people who have different
points of view and think about the world
in very different ways
you also want to pay attention to who
these characters are that is why
somebody again like if you're doing the
symposium maybe reading rosen could be
quite helpful
plato is drawing most of his characters
from people that actually lived in
ancient athens or in other environing
towns like meno is an out of towner for
example right as is credo
so it's it's important to know enough
about these people
that you can make sense of them but you
should also realize that you know plato
is also
sometimes putting his own spin on things
he's a creative writer he is not just a
philosopher he's also a poet he's also a
dramatist
and the characters are representing
sometimes types of people so
thrasymachus in the republic represents
the type of the brash sophist the person
who comes in and has all the answers and
wants everyone to shut up so he can he
can tell his story right you've seen
that sort of type before i think right
and glaucon is the the sort of person
who's a young person he thinks that
socrates has something to tell him and
he's going to squeeze socrates until he
gets the doctrines out of him and he's
even going to play devil's advocate
so it's important to attend to the
characters
another thing to think about is the the
the dialogues often have a dramatic
setting
and you don't have to you know
necessarily think that the setting
determines everything but it is worth
paying attention to the arguments that
are contained within the dialogues and
philosophy is in very much respect about
arguments the arguments are what we
could call occasioned they don't just
get made out of the blue
or because somebody wants to write
something down they're being made
between people at a given point in time
and the argument will kind of meander
around and sometimes they'll lose the
thread and they'll have to come back to
it
they're not being entirely
systematically worked out but they are
being developed
to some degree
this requires something from you as a
reader you have to correlate things
especially when you're reading across
different dialogues you're going to say
oh i saw that sort of thing being
referenced back in the photo this is why
it's nice to have an anthology because
you can have all the books in one place
you could be like oh you know this is
about courage
and didn't i remember reading about
courage back and in this work here what
did he say about that so you have to do
some sort of cross-checking and some
comparison and putting the pieces
together that's important for you as a
reader now you don't have to do it all
at once that's the good news right
read one text at a time but keep in mind
that you're going to find the same
issues being looked at from different
sides in the platonic dialogues the last
thing i want to say about it is socrates
as plato's mouthpiece will sometimes
make some really bad arguments
is that because plato is you know just
stupid and didn't know any better
no i think that the reason why
we see socrates sometimes making bad
arguments is because
you have to look at who he's speaking to
he's speaking to somebody who himself
generally
there's only a few female characters
can't recognize
a good argument when it's being made or
isn't able to to really question the
grounds that socrates is going at but
you as the reader can
these these dialogues when plato is
making a bad argument he's expecting you
to get into the conversation and say
wait a second socrates what about this
that's what makes these dialogues
particularly rich and productive they
can suck you as the reader
into them
so that's uh some some
tips that you could say stem from the
nature of the dialogue form
there are a few concerns that that
people often bring up that i would like
to
say a little bit about because i want to
not necessarily dismiss them but at
least
make them not so pressing for you if
you're the kind of person who gets
really concerned about this and and i
really have
four main ones to bring up although
there could be some others as well so
the first of these is what we call the
socratic problem
plato uses socrates as a character in
his dialogues
we think and when i say we i mean the
people who study plato professionally
we think that that some of the dialogues
do represent socrates as he really was
they are probably things that socrates
was saying and then we think that some
other dialogues socrates is just being
used as a mouthpiece and plato is
attributing to socrates and having him
say things that socrates himself
probably didn't think or even think of
and then there's some stuff in the
middle and the question is well how do
you draw the line and the answer is
nobody actually has a cut-and-dried way
of doing this that everybody agrees with
there is some agreement that that like
for example the apology that probably
represents socrates a lot of the early
dialogues and we're going to talk about
that early middle late problem in just a
second those are probably socratic as
well some things you know much later
probably not you know
most scholars tend to think today that
the doctrine of forms the way that plato
articulates it that that probably is not
platonic um although you know aristotle
certainly seemed to think that that it
was um at least in some respects but you
know we don't really know
so that that's um one thing
the question to ask yourself is can you
read plato's dialogues and understand
what is being articulated
without having to know did socrates
himself say this historically and the
answer is yes
whether he did say it or didn't say it
it's a it's a work of literature it's a
work of philosophy if it helps you to
instead of calling them socrates call
him you know jim jam from planet booboo
or something like that do that and
that'll help you not get so worked up
about oh did socrates actually say this
that's a separate problem that we we
don't necessarily need to worry about
when we're figuring out what did plato
actually uh you know think uh and what
is he trying to get across in these
dialogues could be that socrates didn't
say anything about the forms and maybe
the doctrine of the forms actually is
right we're more interested in do the
doctrines themselves make sense
now the second thing is this early
middle late and you'll see this being
referred to in the secondary literature
on plato you know that this dialogue is
obviously a late dialogue or this
dialogue is an early one or this one is
a middle one
and then they'll even break it into like
early middle late middle you know um
and there are some really cool theories
out there about that some of them are
based on things like the stylometrics of
it uh others are based on you know what
what ideas are showing up or when the
dot the dialogue is supposed to be said
or the degree of sophistication of it
when it comes down to it and this is
something that i've devoted quite a bit
of study to back when i was in graduate
school
nobody really knows
i mean we we can guess
that well the republic was probably
written later than the apology
and
a lot of the stuff in the republic is
not coming directly from socrates
himself
but we don't actually know
and and the scholars who put forth
theories
they often are relying on rather
circular
arguments in order to make this work do
you yourself need to decide any of these
things in order to
read understand appreciate and decide
whether you agree with plato or not no
you don't need to worry about that if
you want to worry about it you certainly
can
a third issue that comes up
particularly in terms of the symposium
but also some of the other dialogues is
about
different ideas about gender and
homosexuality and particularly male male
relations
some people get quite turned off by that
you know finding out that the symposium
for example is a set of speeches about
love uh in which uh male male
relationships are are featured quite
heavily and the characters themselves
within the story are in fact lovers of
each other
keep in mind that platonic love
is not physical and so plato himself and
socrates also as a character are not
actually
endorsing you know these these very
physical male male relationships often
with incredible power differentials
you know that is part of the story but
it's a lot more complicated than
people might present the last thing that
i think people often get really hung up
on it has to do with the republic
is the republic supposed to be a
blueprint for plato's ideal society
or is this a sort of ironic gesture that
goes on for pages and pages that
socrates is making that's something we
use to criticize our existing uh you
know polities and governments and those
of ancient cities
again we don't really know
there are theories about this
you don't have to stake out a position
in order to be able to appreciate the
republic the first thing is to actually
read it and then to understand it and
then worry about whether it could be
realized in real life and whether that
would be a good thing or not so those
are some
possible roadblocks or obstacles that i
just want to say
you know we can register them but you
can steer around them you don't have to
make them central to yourself
the last things that i'm going to say
just to wrap this up because it's
already be becoming quite an extensive
discussion
is there's a few other issues that
people might bring up one of them is
people ask well what pace should i be
reading these dialogues at and my answer
to that is well it depends on you
depends on the person
the key thing is that you understand
what you're reading
and you don't try to rush it you can't
blaze your way through
and speed read philosophy you're just
not going to get that much out of it and
a text that you know i can read
now i'm not going to read any plato for
the first time because i've already read
all of plato but something that i
re-read and get something out of in the
space of an afternoon it might take you
a day it might take you a week but
that's because we're different people
and i've got more experience in reading
this so i can see the connections more
easily and it's perfectly fine
you can take whatever time you want as a
matter of fact i strongly suggest doing
that another question people ask is well
how can i tell when i'm done reading the
text how can i tell i've put in enough
work
some people are you know questioning do
i have to master the text no
absolutely not that you know just think
about this
you wanted to read your way through
plato and just read half of his
dialogues this is a lot you know we're
talking about like 700 pages or so of of
material to work your way through
you don't need to master anything you
just need to keep making improvement and
you don't even have to like only read
plato until you've finished reading
plato you know before you go on to
aristotle or nietzsche whoever it's up
to you you're the reader you're the one
who said it's your education you're the
one who gets to decide
feel empowered
the last thing that i'll say is i have
been developing resources to help people
understand and and you know work their
way through platonic texts for a lot of
time
and some of these are you know things i
produced for my own students and classes
you know the lecture videos handouts
recently podcast stuff
i don't have them available right now
but i will be
in the near future
having some online courses that will be
available
some of them free and some of them very
very inexpensively if you want to work
your way through platonic dialogues they
will be available in the study with
sadler academy online
there's lots and lots and lots of other
great resources out there that you can
access for free or you can pay for as
well tons of courses i'm just mentioning
that i'll have my own in case you know
that's that's something that appeals to
you but there's lots of other great
stuff available as well you should avail
yourself of those those resources if it
helps your study great if it supports it
that's great if you can do it on your
own now that you've you know
been
fortified with a little bit of
encouragement and you can work your way
through it more power to you the key
thing is to
read plato
and just keep working at it and develop
a
systematic sense of what's going on in
those texts and where plato fits into
the history of philosophy and if you do
that
i promise you it will be rewarding the
last thing i'll say
every one of you are up to the task of
reading plato so just dive in don't
don't you know hesitate don't put it off
until next weekend don't put it off till
next semester or next year just get into
it start studying him and or if you have
already been studying plato read read
some more
and you'll find yourself
learning so much in the process
you